je me réjouis que ce débat puisse avoir
lieu o senhor hémicycle temps ce sujet
suscite à la fois de vive inquiétude et
des récupérations politiques toutes
sortes
c'est un sujet sensible et c'est heureux
qu'ils soient qu'ils le restent
c'est un sujet sensible et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous devons
l'aborder
vous l'aurez compris je me félicitais
comment groupe
un soir à initiative aussi tenu à
remercier mes collègues et les avec toi
nos et jean pierre godefroy pour le
rapport d'information qui aujourd'hui
quatre ans après doit sans doute être de
nouveau actualisé notre pays peut
s'enorgueillir d'être une terre
d'accueil etc afin qu'ils puissent le
reste et que nous devrons être ferme
avec ceux qui chercheraient à dévoyer sa
politique il faut parfois le rappeler
lorsque nous évoquons des mineurs non
accompagnés
nous parlons avant tout de vies brisées
et d'un fan des racines et oui tout
infâme privé de son milieu familial sur
notre sol mérite notre protection
certains individus sans vergogne un
cherchent à bénéficier des moyens qui ne
le sommes pas réservé et nuisant ainsi à
la qualité de prise en charge de ces
mineurs en grande difficulté
cet accueil qui est d'abord un drame
humain a aussi un coûte 2 milliards
d'euros par an et l'assemblée des
départements de france nous alerte en
estimant que soit ce que près de 70% de
prétendus mineurs ne le sommes pas en
réalité je vous laisse faire le calcul
pour pouvoir être à la hauteur de notre
idéal
nous devons sans relâche et de manière
concomitante lutter contre les réseaux
qui exploitent cette misère humaine
certains témoignages au cda se sont
édifiants en effet il arrive que le
personnel voit plusieurs individus se
présenter devant eux avec exactement
exactement le même certificat de
naissance sans scrupules
ces individus avec l'aide de passeurs
cherche à être identifiés comme mineur
et connaissent parfaitement notre
système administratif et ses failles nos
départements sont débordés et l'écoutent
imposées sont très supérieurs à la
compensation accordée par l'état sous
cette présidence
et après des heures de négociations la
participation de l'état est passé de 12
à 14% alors qu'en 2010 six mineurs
étaient 4000 compris comme contre eux
préparent dans de 40000 aujourd'hui
j'évoque des courts imposés
car le gouvernement ne fait rien pour y
remédier en effet certains départements
par idéologie ou devrais je dire posture
politicienne fragilise l'ensemble notre
politique l'accueil la gestion du flux
migratoire n'est pas une compétence
départementale mais bien régaliennes il
s'agit désormais à l'état de porter ses
responsabilités c'est bien l'état qui
rend possible qu un tiers des
départements se refuse aux
renseignements d'un fichier national
recensant les demandes de prise en
charge et ainsi permettre de lutter
contre les demandes répétitives et
abusive
aujourd'hui des individus reconnus
majeur dans un département peuvent en
sauce solliciter un autre puis un autre
puis un autre
d'autant que nos forces de l'ordre se
retrouve également dans l'incapacité de
connaître la minorité ou non d'une
personne interpellée est donc de
faciliter soit sa prise en charge par la
zone lorsqu'elle effectivement mineurs
ou son expulsion du territoire
lorsqu'il en est rien dans un article
publié dans midi libre
le 7 novembre dernier le ministre de
l'intérieur se désole qu'il n'y ait pas
d'obligation à remplir ce fichier
heureusement que vous êtes aux affaires
monsieur le ministre
heureusement que vous disposez d'une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
ces départements handicap sciemment
notre politique d'accueil et
je le crains l'incitation financière née
du décret du 23 juin 2020 ne sera pas
suffisante
une nouvelle fois il s'agit de
décourager des individus qui cherchent à
bénéficier des deux dû à des mineurs en
détresse pour y parvenir puisque ces
personnes ne se présente sous de faux
papiers
quand elle ne se présente pas sans
papiers nous devons pouvoir recourir aux
tests osseux qui même s'ils ne sont pas
infaillibles contribuer à un faisceau d
indices dont nous ne pouvons pas passer
à la matière prenons le teint à cet
égard de préciser qu'il s'agit d'une
simple radio qui par ailleurs peut être
refusé en somme nous devons nous
préoccuper de la véracité de la
situation du demandeur
il importe de constater sa minorité
comme son isolement en la matière nous
devons nous donner beaucoup plus de
moyens il y à peu j'ai eu à solliciter
la direction de l'accueil de la
préfecture du gard au sujet d'un visa
ils sont débordés
alors même qu'il s'agit d'une
ressortissante de bonne foi et faisant
ce constat je ne pouvais que
m'interroger dans sa perplexité sur le
suivi que pour être réservée aux
demandeurs dont la majorité avaient été
établies
cette tentation que certaines
département fenêtre fait le jeu de
réseaux mafieux d'abord parce que ce
débouté bien qu'un situation irrégulière
n'en sonne pas moins sur le sol français
et quant à l'atteinte d'un éloignement
ils devront subvenir à leurs besoins
c'est alors à cette occasion de ces
réseaux profitent cette vulnérabilité
aussi et c'est peut-être encore plus
grave parce que les enfants bel et bien
mineur ne sommes plus à mesure des
costumes en encadré qui peuvent être
facilement embrigader ses réseaux
sont alors doublement gayan et j'espère
ne pas être le seul à ne pas me résoudre
car cette générosité d'apparat facile à
tenir un discours nuit à notre capacité
d'accueil ses enfants car nous parlons
bien d'un fai doivent pouvoir suivre une
formation est relogé être suivi et cela
représente un coût estimé à 50 mille
euros par an et par enfant sans compter
d'éventuels frais de santé
chaque année le flux de prétendus
mineurs est estimé à 37 mille personne
je dis bien chaque année rappelons qu'un
enfant de 14 ans doit être au minimum
accompagner dignement durant les
prochaines quatre années nous pouvons
laisser de faux mineurs user de notre
générosité et ainsi grever l'assistance
à ces jeunes au parcours déjà si
difficile à n'ayant dressé ce tableau
j'espère monsieur le ministre que vous
aurez perçu qui ne s'agit pas là d'un
enjeu départementale mais bien national
et qui vont revient d'y apporter une
réponse à la hauteur
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur adrien taquet secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enfance et des familles
pour 8 minutes m
oui monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur burgoa merci pour
vos merci pour vos mots d'abord d'avoir
évoqué la sensibilité du sujet que nous
allons évoquer en cette fin d'après midi
d'avoir rappelé que ces enfants car ce
sont des enfants vous l'avez répété à
plusieurs reprises mérite notre
protection
c'est un devoir
c'est notre honneur aussi que de
protéger les enfants d'avoir dit qu'il
fallait faire montre de pragmatisme et
et n'ont pas d'idéologie de récupération
politique
merci à vous au groupe l'est républicain
de porter ce sujet aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle
un sujet qui fait l'objet évidemment
d'un travail interministériel important
concerne nombreuses administrations
ministères de la justice de l'intérieur
et solidarité de la santé l'éducation
nationale je reviendrai sur ce que vous
avez dit évidemment
s'agissant de l'articulation entre
l'état et les départements
depuis que j'ai été nommé il ya de cela
deux ans à l'enfance et aux familles
j'ai demandé à assurer le pilotage de
cette question là avec l'ensemble des
autres ministres et ministère de ce
gouvernement
pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez dit ce
sont des enfants et qu'il était normal
que ce soit le ministre chargé de
l'enfance qui est la responsabilité de
ce sujet là
derrière cet acronyme que nous allons
beaucoup utilisé cet après midi est
maintenant ne jamais oublier qu'il ya
des personnes et a les chiffres les
procédures que nous allons évoquer ne
jamais oublier qu'il ya des enfants et
qu'à ce titre je le répète ils doivent
être protégés derrière cet acronyme
aussi il ya des réalités très
différentes
on va parler des maynats comme d'un bloc
homogène ce qui n'est pas conforme à la
réalité il ya autant de réalités
différentes comme il ya autant d'enfants
parce que chaque enfant est différent
ces enfants viennent de pays différents
quel point commun entre un enfant du
bangladesh
l'enfant qui vient du mali du maghreb si
ce n'est peut-être qu'il est un enfant
et qu'il a le droit à la protection en
tant que tels ces enfants des
modifications pour rejoindre notre pays
qui sont différentes
ils ont des parcours migratoire très
différents et ils ont aussi une volonté
d'intégration de notre pays qui peut
différer c'est une réalité ça aussi
alors c'est un sujet d'hiver c'est un
sujet complexe et depuis je m'en occupe
je vous le dis en toute sincérité
j'essaie de faire montre d'humilité
parce que c'est un sujet compliqué et je
sais que c'est un sujet compliqué pour
les départements et pour les élus locaux
certain nombre d'entre vous avez été le
trac baptisme loin de toute idéologie et
avec une seule boussole l'intérêt de
l'enfant et je souhaite que ce débat
vous l'avez souhaité également monsieur
le sénateur suivent ces quelques grands
principes
loin de tout amalgame le tout raccourci
de toute généralité dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
d'ailleurs alors
pour bien débattre je pense qu'il va
voir une situation précise de la réalité
donc je me permet de partager avec vous
quelques chiffres vous l'avez dit on a
parfois les mêmes parfois il diffère un
peu nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir à
travers les différentes questions qui me
seront adressées effectivement ils
n'étaient que 13 mille mineurs non
accompagnés en 2016 sur notre territoire
au 31 décembre 2019 ce sont trente et un
mille mineurs non accompagnés
l'augmentation a été particulièrement
forte vous le savez sur deux années
précise puisqu'entre fin 2016 fin 2018
le nombre de mineurs non accompagnés a
crû de plus de 115 %
depuis la situation a quelque peu changé
plus de alors que plus de 17000
personnes avaient été reconnues mineurs
en 2018
sachez que ce chiffre a rechuté à 9000
en 2020 reconnaissance de minorité vous
savez déjà qu'en 2019 il y avait déjà eu
une légère diminution puisque le en
termes de flux excusez moi de le terme
nous avions baissé de 1,5 pour cent et
j'aurai l'occasion à l'occasion de ce
débat de revenir sur ces fluctuations
95% de ces mineurs sont des garçons la
grande majorité 77% ont 15 et 16 ans ils
viennent principalement vous le savez de
guinée du mali et de côte d'ivoire pour
deux tiers d'entre eux et du maghreb
légère progression ces dernières années
à peu près à hauteur de 10%
c'est environ 1771 jeunes qui viennent
du maghreb qui sont aujourd'hui sur
notre territoire la face à cette ré
cette réalité le gouvernement les
pouvoirs publics les départements veille
à améliorer la protection de ces mineurs
trois exemples la contribution que vous
évoquez monsieur le sénateur de l'état
au département financière comprend un
forfait dédié à la réalisation de bilans
de santé quand les 500 euros par jeune
évaluer la mise à l'abri 100 euros sont
consacrés nous l'avons souhaité au bilan
de santé à la fois physique et psychique
de ces jeunes et on peut avoir ainsi une
première évaluation sachez par ailleurs
que nous avons souhaité que le renforce
un renforcement de ce bilan de santé
notamment sur la partie évaluation
psychologique
on peut comprendre aisément que ces
jeunes puissent souffrir juste qu'ils
ont vécu de certains certains
traumatismes psychologiques et donc là
le renforcement de son bilan santé fasse
partie des réflexions d'une mission
quadripartite que nous avons missionné
avec le ministre de l'intérieur le
ministre de la justice le ministre de la
santé et moi-même en octobre dernier
c'est un enjeu majeur dont découle
évidemment énormément de difficultés
cette mission quadripartite sur la
question de l'évaluation et de la prise
en charge des mineurs non accompagnés
devrait rendre ses conclusions d'ici la
fin du premier semestre
même logique de l'amélioration de la
protection
avec ça vous surprendra peut-être que je
l'évoqué ce moment là le fichier à l'om
d'être d'évaluation à la minorité on y
reviendra aussi j'imagine ce fichier
vous l'avez dit permet de faire en sorte
que ça soit les mineurs effectivement
mineurs qui bénéficient du système de
protection et non pas des majeures qui
viendraient emboliser le système ce
fichier c'est aussi une protection pour
les mineurs
ceux qui ont été évalués le mineur s'ils
changent de département ne peuvent plus
se voir contester leur minorité comme ça
pouvait se passer par le passé c'est ça
aussi le fichier à m nous y reviendrons
dernier exemple meilleure protection
d'un meilleur accompagnement des jeunes
mineurs non accompagnés
la circulaire publiée par le ministre de
l'intérieur en septembre dernier visant
à proposer aux mines ans non accompagné
placé à allah je engagés dans un
parcours professionnalisant d'anticiper
l'examen de leur droit au séjour à la
majorité on ne peut plus attendre 18 ans
- l'écart pour se poser la question de
l'insertion professionnelle d'un jeune
il faut que dès 17 ans au plus tard on
commence préfecture et département à se
poser ces questions-là
enfin vous me laissez un peu rapidement
conclure quelques instants les instants
pour aborder l'accompagnement de l'état
auprès des départements mais j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
quelques exemples là aussi on y
reviendra dans le détail vous savez que
le programme 304 est destiné justement à
la participation financière auprès des
départements de la part d'états de la
part de l'état avec d'une part une
participation forfaitaire vous avez
parlé d'heures de négociations le seul
sénateur
ce mécanisme a été élaboré avec
l'association des départements de france
nous sommes mis d'accord pour
effectivement qu'un forfait de 90 euros
pendant 80 pendant 14 jours puis de 20
euros pendant neuf jours un jour fait de
6000 euros par jeune mineur non
accompagné supplémentaires par rapport à
l'année suivante sur un quorum de 75%
soit fasse l'objet d'une contribution de
l'état au département c'était 96
millions d'euros en 2018
33 millions d'euros en 2019 selon les
nouveaux critères et puis à l'aide
exceptionnelle le dispositif cazeneuve
qui a été reconduit depuis dès mon
arrivée
un président de conseil départemental
stéphane troussel pour ne pas le nommer
m'a alerté sur des difficultés liées à
la clé de répartition des mineurs non
accompagnés je me suis engagé à ce que
nous revoyons cette clé de répartition
afin qu'il y ait une répartition plus
équitable qui tienne davantage compte de
la situation de chaque département
c'est ce que nous avons fait deuxième
exemple il faut de l'accompagnement jeu
conclut monsieur le président de
l'accompagnement de l'état face aux
départements et je développerai d'autres
aspects de cet accompagnement au travers
des questions dont je ne doute pas que
vous devez l'aborderai au fil de nos
échanges voilà vous
l'occasion de revenir sur un certain
nombre de points monsieur le ministre
merci et
la parole est à mme adam eliane assassi
la présidente eliane assassi pendant
pour le grosser ce pour deux minutes
heure merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une fois de plus nous sommes invités à
débattre de ce sujet des mineurs non
accompagnés autrefois qualifiés de
mineurs isolés étrangers ce qui
définissait selon nous bien mieux leur
véritable statut d'enfant étrangers se
trouvent se trouvant seul c'est à dire
sans responsable sur notre territoire
mon groupe était à l'initiative d'un
débat sur ce thème en 2018
en posant des l'intitulé du débat la
question de la prise en charge de ces
mineurs ici nos collègues n'ont pas posé
de problème à tiques précise mais à
l'image de la mission d'information en
cours à l'assemblée nationale ne
s'agirait-il pas d'évoquer
principalement les problèmes de nature
diverse qui serait causée par ces
mineurs et de la réponse pénale à
adopter je m'interroge nous ne
partageons pas évidemment cette approche
du sujet forcé à un exil dont nous avons
une part de responsabilité tributaire de
nos politiques migratoires cmn à sont
victimes d'enfermement aux frontières
dans les centres de rétention
administrative dans les zones d'attentes
avant d'être bien souvent criminaliser
pointé du doigt je vous le redis avec
force nous pouvons traiter ces mineurs
étrangers autrement que comme nos
propres enfants
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et la
protection de l'enfance doivent toujours
primer c'est pourquoi il est maintenant
nécessaire et urgent de mettre en place
avec le dispositif d'accueil et de prise
en charge ces mineurs en cessant
immédiatement tout enfermement de ces
mineurs étrangers et en garantissant
leur mise à l'abri inconditionnels en
cessant également le recours aux tests
osseux enfin nous vous le demandons
monsieur le ministre ne serait-il pas
temps d'instaurer un dispositif financé
bien sûr de prise en charge de ces
mineurs isolés étrangers qui seraient
juridiquement contraignant pour tous les
conseils départementaux notamment en
termes de places d'hébergement en foyer
en famille d'accueil est en poste
deux travailleurs sociaux merci
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
le ministre pour deux minutes
ainsi monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
ce dispositif que vous appelez de vos
voeux en réalité existe existe des gens
il y a une obligation ça relève de nos
obligations internationales de notre
droit interne de mettre à l'abri toutes
personnes se déclarant mineurs
c'est ce que font effectivement les
conseils départementaux et je commençais
à l'évoquer l'état accompagne et d'un
point de vue financier
je vais développer mais aussi sur le
fond les départements s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un nombre de départements
ou des associations auxquelles il
déléguait la question de l'évaluation
que vous évoquez des difficultés mais
iniquité traitement aussi du point de
vue des enfants de territoire à
territoire c'est la raison pour laquelle
notamment la direction générale de la
cohésion sociale a émis un guide
d'évaluation de la minorité afin
d'homogénéiser les pratiques et bd les
départements dans cette danse est cette
mission lors donc obligation
méfions-nous aussi de ne pas faire de
distinguo entre les enfants de ne pas
filia risée excusez moi du terme je
l'utilisais à des cent des enfants les
enfants mineurs non accompagnés ont
droit à la même protection une fois
qu'ils ont été évalués mineurs à la même
protection que les enfants nés sur le
territoire
le territoire national donc ce droit
inconditionnel
il existe il ya une évaluation de la
minorité qui est fait dont vous savez
qu'elle doit répondre à un faisceau
d'indicés évaluation sociale
une fois encore dont les modalités ont
été précisées dans le cadre du guide
d'évaluation de la direction générale de
la cohésion sociale la possibilité de
recourir
vous l'avez évoqué aussi aux tests
osseux de façon très encadrée de
décision du conseil constitutionnel une
précisément encadrent le recours aux
tests se dit que en tant que tel cela ne
peut pas constituer
une preuve de l'âge d'un enfant parce
que l'on sait les scientifiques nous le
dise en particulier à cet âge là est
très difficile d'avoir des certitudes
sur l'âge de l'enfant de l'enfant
concerné mais que par ailleurs ça ne
porte pas atteinte aux principes de
dignité humaine donc le recours est
encadré ça ne peut être qu'un faisceau
parmi d'autres c'est décidé c'est décidé
vous savez sur décision judiciaire bref
c'est encadré
voilà madame là je dépasse beaucoup déjà
monsieur le président je m'en excuse
merci monsieur le ministre une réplique
madame la présidente tu as aussi non
merci merci monsieur ministre pour votre
réponse mais j'ai quand même le
sentiment que vos propos se heurte au
principe de réalité
les droits des enfants et
particulièrement des enfants étrangers
isolés ne sont pas respectueux et
respecté puisque nous savons très bien
et vous le savez que des enfants sont
enfermés dans des centres de rétention
reste dans les zones d'attentes et
kitchen et leurs droits ne sont pas du
tout respecté et je crois qu'il serait
temps de regarder ce principe de réalité
avec courage et d'essayer d'y trouver
pas d'essayer de trouver les remèdes
pour qu'il n'en soit plus ainsi que les
droits de l'enfant soit véritablement
respecter aussi chers collègues la
parole est à madame élisabeth doineau
pour deux minutes pour le groupe union
centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues tout d'abord
merci à notre collègue laurent burgoa
d'avoir initié ce débat est également
d'avoir rappelé ce rapport que nous
avions pu faire avec notre ancien
collègue jean pierre godefroy
nous nous étions à l'époque concentrer
sur les questions complexes concernant
l'évaluation des jeunes mineurs non
accompagnés et aussi sur l'hébergement
ça reste deux sujets
deux questions centrales comme en
témoigne le récent rapport d'ailleurs de
l'igas je voudrais aussi signaler que
nous avions émis 30 propositions afin
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
mineurs non accompagnés à cette époque
mais je souhaite ici rebondir sur
l'actualité pour évoquer la question de
la formation et de l'obtention d'un
titre de séjour
vous avez en mémoire le boulanger
stéphane ravva clé qui a entamé une
grève de la faim pour que son apprenti
puisse obtenir un titre de séjour ce
qu'il a obtenu depuis d'ailleurs la
situation de l'ail et fodé traoré n'est
malheureusement pas isolé dans notre
pays
vous avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
les nouvelles dispositions pour
anticiper effectivement ce droit au
séjour depuis septembre dernier
mais pour y remédier vraiment il y a
encore des freins il y encore des freins
et nous évoquions dès 2017 trois
propositions
d'abord de renforcer les partenariats
entre 15,9 et direct afin d'identifier
les formation professionnelle et
d'apprentissage rendant plus facilement
les émana éligibles au titre de séjour
au moment de la majorité de leur
majorité c'était la proposition numéro
ensuite nous avions proposé de modifier
l'article l313 tiré 15 du ceseda afin
que le critère de suivi d'une formation
à l'admission au titre de séjour soit
élargie aux formations d'enseignement
général c'était la proposition numéro 28
pour time terminée nous avions proposé
de réitérer par circulaire le droit
inconditionnel d amman a à se voir
délivrer une autorisation provisoire de
travail dans le cadre d'une formation
c'était la proposition numéro 30
aussi monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous indiquer quelles mesures vous
comptez mettre en oeuvre afin que les
mineurs non accompagnés engagés dans une
formation puisse réellement bénéficié
d'un parcours plus facilitant dans
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour
si cher collègue monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président merci madame la
sénatrice de ne pas avoir cité gestion
propos introductif le rappeur vous aviez
commis je vous en remercie notamment
pour les propositions dont un certain
nombre sont encore en expertise chez
nous mais vous dire d'ores et déjà
peut-être que nous avons mis en place je
l'évoqué brièvement vous l'avez évoqué
la nécessité d'anticiper les situations
pour éviter les ruptures il ya une
circulaire du 20 et 21 septembre 2020 du
ministre de l'intérieur qui est parti à
l'ensemble des préfectures afin qu'ils
se rapprochent des départements c'est
partie du terrain sera que c'était un
déplacement dans l'oise sauf erreur ou
effectivement la préfecture le président
du conseil départemental avait mis en
place cette convention qui faisaient
qu'à 17 ans au plus tard on se mettait
autour de la table et on regardait la
situation du jeune sans lui promettre
forcément qu'il aurait des papiers à 18
ans mais déjà pour voir dans quel
parcours d'études professionnalisant ils
s'inscrivaient et afin de pouvoir
dresser une trajectoire faire baisser un
peu la pression qui reposait sur
l'épaule du jeune parce qu'il avait
d'ores et déjà un peu plus de
perspectives c'est tout le sens de la
circulaire qui a été envoyé et dont je
sais qu'elle n'est pas encore forcément
appliqué sur l'ensemble du territoire il
s'avère madame la sénatrice que le
boulanger que vous évoquiez j'étais au
téléphone avec lui cet après midi
justement pour échanger un peu sur la
situation maintenant que la situation
était redescendu en quelque sorte
d'échangé échangé sur la situation du
jeune qui n'est effectivement pas un pas
un cas isolé
deuxième sujet peut-être dans l'esprit
d'une des propositions vous évoquiez
dispositif que nous avons annoncées
récemment pour tous les jeunes de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance mais qui concerne
aussi les mineurs non accompagnés la
question de l'insertion professionnelle
nous avons signé avec la ministre
brigitte klinkert avec sous le haut
patronage j'ai envie de dire de l'adf
avec la l'union nationale des missions
locales dont une de vos collègues et
vice présidente mais je ne la vois pas
ici aujourd'hui
ainsi qu'avec la page nous avons signé
une convention afin que les missions
locales
in his une démarche d'aller vers
les jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
qu'il puisse aller dans les foyers
auprès d'eux là aussi à 17 ans au plus
tôt plus tard au moment de l'entretien
d'autonomie afin de voir dans quel
parcours ils s'inscrivent et quels
dispositifs notamment tous ces
dispositifs que nous avons déployés dans
le cadre d'un jeune est une solution
quels dispositifs peuvent être mis à
leur disposition
vous l'avez peut-être vu aussi j'ai
annoncé que pour les jeunes de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance une merci solution
financière de 500 euros seront également
attribués pour tous ces jeunes qui n'ont
ni formation ni emploi par ailleurs
merci monsieur le ministre
donc la parole est à monsieur hussein
bourgi du groupe socialiste écologiste
républicains pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis de ce débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui et je voulais remercier nos
collègues du groupe républicain qui nous
en donne l'occasion
monsieur le ministre dans un courrier du
8 octobre dernier le président de la
cour des comptes pierre moscovici et
écrivait au premier ministre de la
france jean castex pour évoquer la
politique publique concernant les
maynats dans ce courrier il pointé un
certain nombre de défaillances et de
carence de la part de l'état dans la
prise en charge de ces mineurs non
accompagnés en tout cas ceux qui se
déclarent comme tel il pointe et en
particulier un manque de pilotage et
d'organisation interministériel il
indiqué même qu'ils étaient fragiles
en filigrane il a indiqué ce que nous
savons tous et toutes
est ce que nous constatons dans nos
départements et mon collègue laurent
burgoa le sais comme moi nous en sommes
les uns et les autres témoins dans nos
départements mitoyens le gard et
l'hérault l'hérault et le gard
nous avons le sentiment que l'état se
défausse sur les départements nous
laissons à nous seuls le soin de prendre
en charge ces mineurs non accompagnés
alors qu une politique ambitieuse une
politique transversale de prise en
charge des mineurs non-accompagnés
devrait réunir autour d'une même table
les départements votre ministère mais
aussi le ministère de l'éducation
nationale le ministère de l'intérieur le
ministère de la justice le ministère de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
il y a ensuite une deuxième point qui
était pointé dans ce courrier c'est la
préparation insuffisante
à la sortie de ces jeunes qui sont
prises en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
aujourd'hui ma question est toute simple
quelles mesures ont été prises depuis
que ce courrier a été adressé quelles
dispositions le gouvernement compte
reprendre dans les prochains mois dans
les prochaines années pour desserrer
l'étau autour des départements c'est un
sujet sensible c'est un sujet sérieux
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir tout à
l'heure mais pour l'immédiat j'aimerais
bien avoir votre éclairage sur le
pilotage et la coordination de l'action
gouvernementale je vous remercie
monsieur ministre perd collègue monsieur
me
pour deux minutes maximum excusez moi je
vais prendre le rythme monsieur le
président merci monsieur le sénateur les
remarques du président de la cour des
comptes concernant effectivement la
conduite le pilotage de mineurs non
accompagnés concernées en fait
s'applique à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
dans son ensemble et ça d'ailleurs fait
l'objet d'un autre rapport de la cour
des comptes à cet égard effectivement
défaut de pilotage insuffisant pilotage
de cette politique et pour rebondir sur
les propos de monsieur le sénateur tout
à l'heure moi j'ai toujours été très
clair avec vous je pense et avec les
présidents de conseils départementaux il
y en a un certain nombre qui sont dans
cette salle j'en ai été élu récemment
que je sais que je salue les temps n'a
pas toujours été au rendez vous de ses
propres responsabilités et de ses
propres compétences et pour moi la
protection de l'enfance ont gelé
toujours dit mur les pins ce n'est pas
une compétence décentralisée c'est une
compétence partagée parce que monsieur
le sénateur la vie d'un enfant qu'ils
soient mineurs non accompagnés ou pas ne
suis pas votre organisation
administrative
notre organisation institutionnelle est
en réalité les points de contact entre
l'état et les départements sont
permanents tout au long de la vie d'un
enfant et on sait par ailleurs ses
enfants puisque l'arrêté plus compliqué
voilà raison qu'on imagine je parle de
tous les enfants d'être sur un enfant ça
vaut aussi pour les maisons accompagne
que leur santé est moins bonne que les
enfants de leur âge
bon ben ça c'est plutôt côté de l'état
que ça se passe la question de
l'accompagnement vers l'autonomie là
aussi un point de contact entre l'état
les départements et effectivement ce que
le point de ce rapport est tout l'enjeu
d'une réforme de la gouvernance de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance qui concerne
six mineurs non accompagnés que je
portais dont j'espère que vous aurez
l'occasion d'en débattre dans les
semaines à venir vise justement à
renforcer ce pilotage et qui a une
meilleure qu'ils aient une meilleure
coopération et une meilleure
coordination entre les différents
intervenants au sein de l'état et entre
l'état et les départements emachines
ministre
une réplique monsieur bourgi pas de
réplique donc je passe la parole à alain
cadec pour les républicains pour deux
minutes
monsieur le ministre
2 milliards d'euros c'est le coût annuel
estimé par les départements pour la
prise en charge des mineurs non
accompagnés
en 2020 le coût d'accueil d'un elena est
estimée à cinquante mille euros par an
comme cela a déjà été dit face à
l'augmentation massive du nombre de
mineurs non accompagnés étrangers qui a
triplé entre 2016 et 2018 même si ça va
un peu mieux maintenant
les services départementaux doivent
s'organiser dans l'urgence sans les
moyens et les structures adaptées sur le
plan budgétaire les dépenses ont
considérablement augmenté
à titre d'exemple en 2016 le département
des côtes d'armor dépensé 2,5 millions
d'euros pour la prise en charge des
mineurs non accompagnés
ce budget est passé aujourd'hui à 8
millions d'euros le département reçoit
certes des aides de l'état mais qui sont
loin de compenser toutes les dépenses en
2019 l'état budget et ainsi seulement
141 millions d'euros alors que le coût
évalué par l'adf et est je le rappelle
de 2 milliards d'euros
c'est un gouffre financier pour les
départements qui s'ajoutent d'ailleurs à
la non-compensation croissante des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
chaque département se voient imposer
chaque année par l'état
un pourcentage de hem et l'aa accueillir
qui se révèlent parfois au terme d'une
procédure d'évaluation ou même au cours
de leur prise en charge
être en fait des majeures l'état laisse
les collectivités gérer seul les
conséquences de son manque de courage
politique
une fois de plus l'état est aux abonnés
absents
la question des maynats est une question
liée à la politique migratoire monsieur
le ministre c'est donc bien une
prérogative régalienne alors cerise sur
le gâteau le gouvernement vient de
décider unilatéralement d'interdire aux
départements d'héberger les maynats dans
des hôtels tout cela sans proposer
d'alternative qui d'ailleurs n'existe
pas monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
at il l'intention de prendre sa part de
responsabilité dans la gestion du flux
mme buffet flux migratoires afin de
désengorger les demandes d'accueil et
d'accompagnement de ces jeunes et
mais ainsi ses responsabilités va-t-il
enfin soutenir efficacement les conseils
départementaux en leur donnant les
moyens nécessaires afin d'accueillir ces
mineurs non accompagnés
je sens le ministre monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur le président quand le
gouvernement moi-même décidons que dans
notre pays on peut pas y avoir d'enfant
à l'hôtel je pense qu'on assume nos
responsabilités tous collectivement en
temps en tant que nation qu'il n'accepte
pas que des gamins de 15 ans dans
certains cas pas dans tous tes dents
tous certains cas n'ont aucun abandon
aucun accompagnement éducatif sont
abandonnés à eux mêmes
madame la sénatrice enfin moi je ne
tombe pas dans la généralité
c'est une réalité et le confinement à
exacerber ça dans certains cas de façon
dramatique
bon je sais que vous me rejoignent sur
ce point là et je voulais je le vous le
répète je fais pas d'idéologie plaisir
je ne fais pas de politique sur ces
sujets là j'ai conscience je sais
pourquoi des enfants sont aujourd'hui à
l'hôtel c'est moi qui ai commandé à
l'igas il ya un nom un rapport déjà pour
connaître la réalité de la situation
parce que tout le monde en parle sans
savoir précisément de quoi on parle
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya entre 7000
et 10 mille mineurs qui sont à l'hôtel
que dans 95 % des cas ce sont
effectivement des mineurs non
accompagnés
5 % des cas sont des enfants à part un
parcours dit complexe
on y reviendra si vous le souhaitez oui
je pense qu'il faut il faut
collectivement que l'on s'assigne un
principe d'interdiction de mineurs à
l'hôtel je pense que nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas l' inverse et il faut
monsieur le sénateur pour être
pragmatique proposer des alternatives
proposait même un encadrement strict
dans le temps sur les modalités
d'accompagnement sur le type d'hôtel
pour que de façon temporaire pour faire
face à une situation telle que celle que
les départements ont connu une forte
année d'arrivée de la mena on puisse
faire face à la situation
voilà c'est la démarche qu'on va initier
et sur laquelle on va travailler
ensemble avec les départements et avec
l'assemblée des départements de france
si monsieur le ministre j'ai noté que le
québec est rapide
non chers collègues non vous pouvez pas
vous avez dépassé les deux minutes
il ya une règle qui fait que quand on a
dépassé 2 minutes on n'a pas de réplique
je suis désolé mais je suis là marolles
et à joël guerriau pour le groupe et
indépendants pour deux minutes
merci président monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais partager un bout un
témoignage en septembre dernier quelques
jours après l'attentât qui a eu lieu
devant les anciens locaux de charlie
hebdo j'ai pu m'entretenir avec une
famille accueillant trois mineurs isolés
étrangers
deux d'entre eux jeunes gens de
nationalité pakistanaise venait du foyer
d'où provenait l'auteur de l'attentât et
je dois dire que plusieurs point mort
interpellés au cours de mes échanges
avec la famille d'accueil
premièrement ces deux jeunes mineurs
considérés de bonne foi le blasphème
comme un crime
il approuvait même l'attentât qui venait
d'être commis
le couple qui les accueillent contre
l'avis des éducateurs a pris le parti de
leur enlever quelques temps après
l'attentât leur téléphone bien par
lequel il entretenait des liens avec
d'autres personnes partageant cette
opinion les deux mineurs ont également
eu une entrevue avec la gendarmerie
j'étais surpris de constater qu'aucun
suivi et dick éducatif ni pédagogique ne
leur avaient été apportés dans leurs
foyers d'origine
pas de cours d'éducation civique leur
permettant de s'intégrer dans
l'acquisition des valeurs de la nation
française
en fait ils viennent avec leur culture
et ignorent la nôtre à ce titre
l'insertion en lieu de vie
plutôt qu'envoyer semble être une bien
meilleure solution les lieux de vie sont
tous ou utiliser nos départements manque
de moyens pour réaliser ces accueils
dans de bonnes conditions
dans le témoignages que j'ai recueillis
les accueillant mois affirmé que ces
jeunes gardé des contacts réguliers avec
leurs familles dans ces cas là si l'on
connaît les parents que l'on peut les
identifier
pourquoi ces jeunes reste-t-il en france
enfin les passeurs sont souvent connus
dans le cas des mineurs non accompagnés
et c'était le cas pour ces deux jeunes
ces gens utilisent la misère du monde
c'est inadmissible monsieur le ministre
quels sont les moyens mis en oeuvre au
niveau français et européen pour les
arrêter et démanteler ces filières aussi
quelles discussions sont en cours avec
les pays de départ des mineurs de non
accompagnés sur ces sujets merci si cher
collègue monsieur ministre merci
messieurs merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le sénateur vous évoquez
énormément de sujets vous référez un cas
dramatiques
d'ailleurs qui avait cessé parce que
vous faites du tout mais à l'époque j'en
ai beaucoup discuté avec la présidente
du conseil départemental mkv qui avec la
vice présidente
[Musique]
chargé en charge de l'enfance qui avait
suscité un serment d' amalgame à
l'époque un puisque souvenu c'est un
jeune qui était passé par l'aide sociale
à l'enfance mais qui en réalité n'était
pas mineur réellement et il il avait
l'anc est effectivement services
départementaux vous avez raison on avait
estimé qu'il n'était pas qu'ils
n'étaient pas mineures et les enquêtes
faites administrative avait montré qu'il
n'y avait eu aucun signe de
radicalisation au sein du foyer
je m'étonne l'entendre que des jeunes
n'ont pas de suivi éducatif puisque
normalement c'est un principe de base et
les travailleurs sociaux sont soumis aux
mêmes règles de signalement de suspicion
de radicalisation s'ils sont confrontés
à ce genre de situation à l'époque
d'ailleurs avec le mistral l'intérieur
nous avions un peu investiguer pour
savoir ce qu'il en était peu de signes
inquiétants nous remonter des foyers ou
des des familles d'accueil très
brièvement merci d'appréhender le sujet
sur ce sur son entente dans son
entièreté son intégralité
oui évidemment il y à une action à mener
avec les pays d'origine et policières de
lutte contre les passeurs et les et les
trafics car un certain nombre de ces
enfants sont effectivement victime
puisqu'il la traite ni plus ni moins et
puis parce que par ailleurs moi j'ai
toujours considéré là aussi sans aucune
idéologie et avec grande humilité car
c'est un sujet qui est complexe et se le
dire nous anime aussi s'agissant des
questions migratoires plus largement
depuis des années moi je considère
effectivement que tout faire pour éviter
qu'un môme de 15 ans se met sur un canot
pneumatique pour traverser la
méditerranée
c'est de la protection de l'enfance et
que nous avons une responsabilité pour
essayer de faire en sorte qu'il ne parte
pas donc ce sont à la fois la lutte
contre les filières clandestines
et puis ce sont des discussions avec les
pays sources pour retenir les enfants et
puis j'y reviendrai peut-être c'est
aussi tout un travail mené par ministère
de l'intérieur sur l'état civil et la
reconstruction de l'état civil dans un
certain nombre de pays d'origine merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues malgré
une baisse conséquente des arrivées en
2020 la situation alarmante dans
laquelle se retrouvent les mineurs non
accompagnés perdure en effet les délais
de traitement de recours de
reconnaissance de minorités auprès d'un
juge peut varier entre 6 et 24 mois
et c'est un jeune arrive sa majorité
avant d'obtenir une réponse
par ailleurs on note de grandes
disparités territoriales dans certains
départements l'évaluation de ces mineurs
ne va durer qu'un seul jour dans
d'autres ils seront placés à l'hôtel
pendant plus de six mois
mais d'une part le placement en hôtel a
été déplié dans un récent rapport de
l'igas et je vous ai sur ce sujet
interpellé par une question et clic
le 4 février dernier d'autre part les
évaluations ne durant quinze jours ne
sont pas plus vertueuse car souvent
elles sont expéditives et les jeunes
sont directement remis à la rue toute
situation comprise il se retrouve ainsi
confronté à des problèmes d'hébergement
et de scolarisation et ne font l'objet
pour beaucoup d'entre eux d'aucune prise
en charge sanitaire notamment dentaires
ceci est problématique en plein hiver et
en pleine pandémie
de ce fait non seulement il apparaît
urgent d'appliquer immédiatement la
présomption de minorités pour ces jeunes
ont recours
mais il convient aussi d'aller au delà
et de tout simplement prendre en compte
leur vulnérabilité afin qu'ils aient
accès à une réelle prise en charge
pluridisciplinaire les associations qui
pallie ses carences ne peuvent pas
remplacer à elle seule l'état
quand celui ci prendra t-il ses
responsabilités je vous remercie
merci monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le président madame là la
sénatrice bassins déjà vous dire que en
moyenne
si vous parliez de délai en moyenne
aujourd'hui les conseils départementaux
directement ou les associations qu'ils
ont délégué à 7
à cet égard évalue en moyenne sous 15
jours et ces dernières années il ya eu
une réduction il ya une réduction d'un
mais c'était un vrai un vrai sujet il ya
une réduction des délais et d'ailleurs
les contributions financières de l'état
vers les départements tels que je vous
les exploser tout à l'heure notamment
les 90 euros pendant 14 jours
on s'est calé aussi ça avait un effet
levier pour essayer aussi de réduire les
délais d'instruction et de dévaluation
de et puis de mise à l'abri en première
premiers éléments
deuxième élément est pas toujours
effectivement compris par les
associations jeu chacun dans son est
dans son rôle mais le fait de recourir à
une fois que vous n'avez pas été
évaluées majeure part des services
d'évaluation vous n'êtes pas considéré
pas évalué mineurs pardon vous êtes
considéré comme n'étant pas mineur et
comme vous êtes comme majeur et le fait
de recourir au juge ce que sont
effectivement un certain nombre
d'associations 1 100 membres de jeune
avec des associations façon assez
systématique dans un 62 territoire n'est
pas un appel ça n'a pas vocation d'appel
de recourir à la justice et donc
effectivement ils sont considérés comme
comme majeurs et ne bénéficient pas mais
une fois encore notre dispositif avec
tous ces bienfaits toutes ses
difficultés ses limites ses points de
friction de tension doit être là pour
protéger avant tout les mineurs et ceux
qui ont été reconnus comme mineur c'est
un peu les mêmes problématiques sur
l'asile et non mais non est ce qu'on
veut c'est protéger déjà ceux qui avant
tout ceux qui en ont le droit et pas
prendre le risque que les vrais mineurs
souffre d'un système qui ne tient plus
la route parce qu'il ya emboliser par
des gens qui ne sont pas neufs 2018 près
de 40000 personnes qui viennent se
déclarer mineurs in fine est 17 à 18
qui sont effectivement mineurs voilà oui
madame lessard merci monsieur le
ministre mais je vais vous dire quand
même que plus de la moitié des jeunes en
recours
accompagnés par des associations sont
finalement je connus mineur par un juge
ou la cour d'appel ce qui représente des
centaines de mineurs laissé par erreur
dans la rue où pendant de longs mois
voire des années
monsieur dominique j'ai suivi pendant
plus d'un mois
les mineurs qui était encore 2e
arrondissement vous avez dépassé le
droit de réplique le moment là il a
rappelé à ses parts dans la bande gaza
vous allez dépasser entre eux dans un
centre et les 60 ans dans la rue madame
benbassa merci non mais écoutez yahia
règlement et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
droit de réplique pour quelques secondes
dont on n'a pas dépassé 2 minutes mais
il faut essayer de respecter sinon on
n'arrivera pas au bout de nos débats et
on va déborder largement sur la soirée
ce qui va retarder encore plus le débat
de ce soir voilà la parole monsieur
thani mohamed soilihi pour le groupe air
des pays pour deux minutes
mais ce président ne se ministre mes
chers collègues lorsqu'elles portent sur
mayotte la question des mineurs
non-accompagnés déborde largement le
champ de la politique de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance ou du secteur associatif
la situation du 101e département reste
en effet singulière sur le territoire
national je ne veux pas éludé en disant
cela
les événements très graves qui se
produisent sur le sol mahorais opposant
deux bandes de jeunes armés et qu'ils
ont très récemment tué deux mineurs la
particularité se retrouve également dans
les chiffres rappelés par le dernier
rapport de la chambre régionale de la
cour des comptes sur le sujet notamment
plus de 4000m ena sont dénombrés en 2016
alors qu'au niveau national les maynats
représente entre 15 et 20% des mineurs
pris en charge par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ase en 2018
il représente plus du double à mayotte
dans une proportion qui a elle même
presque doublé en deux ans cette
situation est d'ailleurs caractérisé
d'atypique pas la cour des comptes qui
dans ce rapport de 2020 justifie ainsi
le fait que ce département ne soit pas
pris en compte dans les données
nationales qu'elles utilisent cette
spécificité c'est aussi celle de la
situation géographique de mayotte qui se
traduit par une pression migratoire
insupportable depuis les comores par
l'absence aussi de répartition entre
départements de la prise en charge des
maynats se trouvant sur le seulement
auraient livré à une grande précarité et
à toutes les vulnérabilités la
complexité grand monsieur le ministre
j'en ai bien conscience et la solution
ne peut se faire au mépris du droit
toutefois vous vous êtes rendus dans
notre territoire en octobre dernier et
avait pu constater ces difficultés à ce
titre quel bilan pouvez vous dresser de
l'action de l'état en appui du
département je pense notamment à la
convention de 2017 relatives au concours
en faveur de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
dans la continuité
quelles actions sont elles envisagées
afin de traiter c'est réelles
difficultés de prise en charge des
maynats dans notre département
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président monsieur le seul
sénateur
vous l'avez vous l'avais dit la
situation à mayotte est pour le moins
atypique
et moi j'ai toujours considéré qu'on ne
pouvait pas depuis paris comprendre
comprendre ce qui était la réalité de la
situation sans s'y rendre sans quasiment
le sentir dans sa chair je fais le même
raisonnement d'ailleurs pour la guyane
je me suis rendu en juillet de l'année
dernière et je me suis rendu vous l'avez
rappelé à mayotte en octobre dernier
avec vous je vous en je vous en remercie
situation est éminemment complexe
stricto sensu ce sont en réalité 300
mineurs non accompagnés
mais effectivement 4000 jeunes qui ne
sont pas totalement isolé puisque grand
nombre d'entre eux une très très grande
majorité d'entre eux ne sont pas isolés
en réalité ils ont des membres de leur
famille qui sont sur le territoire
mahorais
mais ce sont
passant qui suit le sont totalement vous
l'avez évoqué une convention spécifique
a été mise en place
support de l'état de 10 millions d'euros
chaque année qui va arriver à son terme
d'ailleurs à la fin de cette année nous
sommes en train de travailler réfléchira
si nous comment nous pouvons poursuivre
cette dotation exceptionnelle
par ailleurs vous le savez au moment de
ma venue jeu j'ai apporté un concours
financier exceptionnel de 2 millions
d'euros
la destination non pas du conseil
départemental mais directement des
associations qui opère auprès des
enfants à mayotte afin de les aider à
créer des places supplémentaires mettre
en place des dispositifs de prévention
spécialisée etc
j'ai par ailleurs tendu la main au
président du conseil départemental
proposant de contractualiser avec l'état
dans le cadre de la stratégie de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
que j'ai déployé président m'a dit qu'il
y réfléchissait je suis toujours à sa
disposition
évidemment pour accompagner le
territoire et puis il ya aussi la
politique de reconduite à la frontière
qui est importante
ce sont 27 mille personnes pas que des
enfants
27000 personnes qui ont été reconduites
essentiellement aux comores pour l'année
2019 avec un objectif à peu près
similaire pour l'année 2020 voilà c'est
l'ensemble de ces dispositions là qui
doivent aider le territoire à faire face
à ses difficultés que vous évoquez merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à la
présidente nathalie delattre pour le
groupe r d est ce pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis deux
ans la quiétude et la sérénité qui
caractérise et notre belle ville de
bordeaux sont perturbées par l'afflux
massif de jeunes étrangers isolés ils
sont livrés à eux mêmes
errant dans le centre-ville et devenant
ainsi les proies idéales de réseaux de
traite d'êtres humains
la hausse des violences et sans
précédent vol à l'arraché cambriolages
agressions trafic de stupéfiants et
d'armes sont devenus monnaie courante
pour la préfecture plus de 40 % de la
délinquance des mineurs à bordeaux
serait le fait de ces mineurs non
accompagnés
1400 d'ores et déjà été pris en charge
par le département
mais au moins 200 postes encore problème
pourtant seule une trentaine d'entre eux
seraient réellement âgés de moins de 10
tant à bordeaux si ce phénomène inquiète
autant nos habitants qu'ils ne désarme
nos forces de police à paris il nous
fait débattre alors que nous ne sommes
toujours pas dotée sur le terrain
d'outils pour les identifier
correctement
nous devons faire ici l'aveu de l'échec
de notre politique d'évaluation de l'âge
de ces étrangers malgré quelques
coopération fructueuse mais lourde avec
l'espagne nous devons mettre un terme
aux polémiques stériles qui surgissent
de toutes parts et nous empêchent
d'avancer sur les tests osseux l'avis du
conseil constitutionnel de 2019 aurait
dû mettre un point d'arrêt à certaines
controverses injustifié d'autant que csd
à main radiologique sous-exploité sont
la seule alternative pour régler
l'épineuse question de la présomption de
minorité monsieur le ministre pourquoi
lorsqu'un jeune migrant souhaite
contester la décision du département
devant un juge pour enfants
seul habilité à statuer définitivement
sur l'âge leur haute cour au
radiographie osseuse n'est pas
systématique
pourquoi cette demande d'appel ne
constitue-t-elle pas une expression de
consentement de sa part je vous remercie
de nous éclairer sur ces points merci
cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice sur la question de
l'évaluation c'est un sujet complexe et
une fois encore dans le droit et dans
les faits les tests ce n'est
garantissent par deux
de connaître précisément là je sais ce
même les scientifiques qui nous le
disent c'est un fait scientifique et
c'est encore plus vrai dans cette
période entre 15 et 18 ans ou le
développement du corps fait qu'il est
très difficile à plusieurs mois près de
déterminer l'âge et donc il serait pas
impossible avec certitude de savoir si
un jeune a 17 ans et demi ou 18 ans et
demi ça ce sont les faits et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous avez
conditionnelle a réaffirmé nécessité que
ces tests osseux sur décision d'un juge
pas systématique sur décision d'un juge
fasse office d'un élément d'un faisceau
d'indicés mobilisés pour évaluer la
minorité avec notamment l'entretien
d'évaluation social qui a été redéfinie
par l'arrêté du 20 novembre 2019 qui
doivent aborder explicitement les
éléments permettant de déterminer l'âge
ou l'état civil les éléments relatifs à
son état de vulnérabilité
les éléments de son projet personnel qui
ont émergé lors de l'évaluation ou
encore les éléments relevés lors des
entretiens qui peut faire douter là pour
le coup de la minorité ou de houe de
l'isolément voilà c'est l'ensemble de
ces éléments qui doivent être appréciés
avec une fois encore politique de
précision et d'homogénéisation de la
part des services d g 16 je l'évoquais
mais aussi mystère l'intérieur est dpjj
que j'ai oublié tout à l'heure puis par
ailleurs madame là la sénatrice vous
êtes en gironde sauf sauf erreur bien
tout de même la question de
l'utilisation du fichier d'être
d'évaluation à la minorité qui dans les
80 et non pas on n'était pas exactement
d'accord monsieur le sénateur dans les
80 départements qui aujourd'hui
l'utilisent ou sont sur le point de
l'utiliser ça a conduit à une baisse de
20 à 30% les jeunes qui se présente
parce que oui avait du nomadisme
administratif et il est important que de
mon point de vue que l'ensemble des
départements utilisent effectivement ce
fichier pour la si bonne tenue de
l'ensemble du système
et puis aussi parce que c'est un élément
de protection des enfants merci beaucoup
pas de réplique
donc la parole et annick jacquemet pour
le groupe union centriste pour deux
minutes
mais si mon nom mais j'ai pas compris
pardon merci les amène à représente
entre 15 et 20% des mineurs pris en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance ce
coût de la prise en charge est estimé en
moyenne à 50 mille euros par mineur et
par an bien plus qu'une radiographie
osseuse et je peux vous assurer que pour
certains scientifiques ces radiographies
sont fiables il faut trouver le moyen de
rendre obligatoire ce texte car beaucoup
de mineurs sont en fait des majeurs vous
parliez d'un fichier moi je vous parle
de la collaboration que l'on a avec en
espagne qui effectivement comme je vous
le disais lourde à mettre en place mais
beaucoup de mineurs en france sont en
fait majeur en espagne parce que vous
savez c'est en espagne et droits pour
les majeurs censure suggérant que miller
en français en france merci jean rivard
y arriver merci madame eric jacquemet
pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
après une dizaine d'années de
l'augmentation exponentielle du nombre
de amène à accueillir dans nos
départements le nombre de jeunes mineurs
étrangers semble se stabiliser
il est temps maintenant de faire
fonctionner correctement le système les
départements réclament de la cohérence
entre l'action de chaque intervenant la
justice l'état et les collectivités
le système souffre en effet d'un
parcours en 2 étapes qui crée de fausses
espérances pour les jeunes et des coups
un duo importants pour les collectivités
j'attire votre attention monsieur le
ministre sur ce qui pourrait constituer
une incohérence dans la mise en oeuvre
de notre politique publique
l'étape à un accueil par la protection
de l'enfance où le doute sont la
minorité profite à l'intéressé et où
l'état civil est rarement reconstituer
les jeunes bénéficient alors d'un
système très généreux qui va les
accueillir les formes et les accompagner
pendant des mois voire des
sans se soucier sans avoir de certitude
sur la suite de leur parcours et l'étape
2 lors du passage à la majorité
les services de l'état peuvent
légitimement relevé des doutes sérieux
sur leur identité et refuser l'accès au
séjour ou à la nationalité française et
les reconduire à la frontière
il apparaît donc nécessaire de fixer
très rapidement dès l'arrivée des
maynats en france les chances pour eux
d'y rester durablement avant qu'il ne
prenne racine dans notre pays sans
espoir de pouvoir y rester et on a parlé
on a évoqué le jeune traoré
le fichier est très efficace il apporte
toutes les garanties aux jeunes en
matière de recours devant le juge des
enfants
son utilisation doit être généralisé à
l'ensemble des départements et il est
nécessaire aussi de fixer très
rapidement les chances pour les maynats
de rester durablement dans un pays on
rendant obligatoire le dépôt anticipé
d'une demande de titre de séjour
six mois après leur arrivée en
mobilisant le réseau diplomatique pour
que les jeunes et les administrations
obtiennent des réponses plus fiable et
en garantissant une réponse rapide des
préfectures les derniers psg fort au
delà une question oui il m'a justement
ça serait articulé la la
et puis le parcours plus rapide au
niveau de la préfecture avec une réponse
rapide
je vous remercie cher collègue monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le président
merci madame la sénatrice et écouter
tout ce que vous évoquez appelez de vos
voeux c'est tout le sens d'une part et
fonctionnement du fait chier à m
à l'occasion duquel les services de la
préfecture vont interroger certains de
base notamment des visas et essayer de
de faire une recherche documentaire en
quelque sorte sur sur ce jeune là on
sait que c'est pas toujours possible on
c'est pas fou il ya des états civils qui
ont été dans certains pays qui sont
notamment confrontés à la guerre je
pense au mali par exemple où l'état
civil les temps est en difficulté il ya
d'autres pays où il ya des difficultés
d'autres ordres avec l'état civil mais
en tout cas à l'occasion
fectivement de la mise en oeuvre de la
des procédures dans le cas du fichier à
m ces recherches documentaires sont
effectuées et par ailleurs c'est tout le
sens de la circulaire du 21 septembre
2020 du ministre de l'intérieur que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure d'une part
d'anticiper les situations c'est à dire
se poser la question de la trajectoire
de ces jeunes n'ont pas trois mois ou au
jour leur majorité comme ça a pu arriver
on incarne des situations ubuesques 18
ans vous disais alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait on mettait en enclencher la
procédure de régularisation sauf que ça
mais de trois mois à le faire donc
penser de trois mois l'enfant n'avait
plus de papier donc le patron qui
l'employait se retrouver dans une
situation illégale donc mettez fin au
contrat d'apprentissage est donc le
jeune enzo de son contrat
d'apprentissage pour avoir ses papiers
banane ne pouvait plus la situation
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut anticiper à 17 ans et c'est
l'occasion aussi là aussi de faire cette
recherche documentaire et de
reconstituer l'état civil étant entendu
que si lors de ces procédures on se rend
compte par la survenance d'éléments
nouveaux
quinze jeunes à manifester mais
manifestement pas mineur et bien on
mettra on mettra fin à la prise en
charge parce que la majorité sera sera
déclarée à ce moment là il aura toujours
la possibilité d'aller devant le juge
pour contester
toujours est il qu'on aura pu
au delà de la situation donc tout ce que
vous avez
je pense que c'est l'esprit et des
procédures mêmes et de la circulaire du
21 merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame victoire jasmin
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicains pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre je remercie aussi le groupe
républicain grâce à ce groupe et bien
nous évoquons ce sujet épineux ce soir
alors en outre mer c'est particulier la
situation géographique permet évidemment
par rapport aux zones frontalières de
recevoir beaucoup de personnes en
situation irrégulière et
particulièrement des mineurs je ne vais
pas évoqué la situation de mayotte parce
que mon collègue vient de le faire mais
en guyane c'est la catastrophe si
j'étais un gars n'y a pas bien longtemps
et j'ai constaté à
saint-laurent-du-maroni que le feu est
régulièrement traversé et qui cela
alimente les réseaux de drogue
on utilise les enfants les jeunes comme
étant des transporteurs de drogue aux
antilles en guadeloupe en martinique est
bien là aussi il y a pas mal d'enfants
qui arrive qui ne sont pas forcément
seuls quelques fois parce qu'ils sont
confiés à les personnes qui sont pas
forcément de leur famille mais ils n'ont
pas de droits parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
lien de parenté et là ça aussi ça
échappe
certains sont mis dans les centres de
rétention
malheureusement est très souvent on le
voit on a contre justement qu'ils soient
renvoyés sur leur territoire respectif
si triste mais c'est la réalité d'autres
alimente les réseaux de la prostitution
et de la drogue est vive dans les squats
ou alors dans des endroits dans les
zones de non droit de dire et ont donc
il est temps aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités mais aussi qu'il y ait
des discussions bilatérales pour
permettre à ces territoires proches de
l'autre de prendre la responsabilité qui
est la leur également parce qu'on ne
peut pas laisser les enfants dans des
situations aussi catastrophiques
quelquefois dans ces zones de non droit
et face à la drogue et à la prostitution
ce qui n'est pas bon pour le pays pour
nos pays respectifs
je vous remercie merci monsieur est
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la sénatrice je vais finir par revenir
sur mayotte que nous avons évoqué avec
monsieur le sénateur la situation et du
spatial et tout aussi compliquée mais
elle est effectivement complexe en
guyane je l'évoquais tout à l'heure je
me suis rendue l'année dernière pour
appréhender ces sujets là et vous avez
raison il ya notamment à saint laurent
du maroni énormément de jeunes de jeunes
mères aussi parfois qui traverse le
traverse le fleuve
ils sont en provenance du surinam pour
une grande partie d'entre eux et la
coopération que surinam à côté avec le
brésil de l'autre même si c'est moins
impressionnant avec l'euro près mais
moins prévenant avec le brésil les
coopérations bilatérales font partie de
la politique que mène le gouvernement
tout comme il le fait aussi
pas toujours simple avec avec les
comores s'agissant s'agissant de mayotte
pour être totalement honnête on a assez
peu de données fiables sur les mineurs
non accompagnés en guyane principale
difficulté réside dans les déclarations
de naissance à l'état civil
parce qu'il ya des populations vous le
savez vous connaissez très éloignées en
forêt
et amazonienne on relève par contre pas
ou peu d'enfants sosie de type de sans
identité originaires d'autres pays
proches qu'ils s'agissent des ti ou de
houe ou dut ou du brésil donc c'est
essentiellement des enfants nés de mères
surinamaise en guyane à saint laurent du
maroni et pour les autorités
surinamaises les enfants menée sur le
territoire français son français
effectueront ne peut pas expulser des
mineurs de notre territoire il ya aussi
un devoir de devoir de protection
ce sont à peu près 1500 enfants suriname
et qu'il naisse en guyane française
chaque année dont un tiers ne sont pas
enregistrés à l'état civil surinamais
mais uniquement à l'état civil français
et puis à la question de la prostitution
et puis à la question des mules que vous
évoquez où effectivement ces jeunes
désoeuvrés sont utilisés pour passer de
la drogue j'ai rencontré les forces de
police des douanes lors de mon voyage et
l'intensification des deux des contrôles
aux frontières dans les vols entre la
guyane et paris avec une augmentation
des des personnes arrêtées dans ce cadre
là nous arrêter parce que si l'on va
durer très longtemps avec ce débat et on
va reporter le suivant très tard
j'espère vous souhaitez répondre
répliqué non donc je passe la parole à
gilbert favreau pour l'europe et
républicains pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues je voudrais pour ma part
parler du nombre des jeunes qui se
trouvent en situation irrégulière en
france
alors on parle tous des mêmes provenance
de ces jeunes qui viennent d'afrique ou
d'asie qui pour la plupart ne sont pas
mineurs sont des majeurs et qui
effectivement par des artifices
juridiques très souvent prolonge le plus
longtemps possible leur présence sur le
sol national
l'évaluation telle qu'elle est organisée
par la france pour vérifier la minorité
montre je viens de dire
ils sont pour la plupart majeur ils font
un recours généralement devant la
justice pour prolonger leur séjour
mais qu'ils soient faux mineurs ou
majeurs anciens mineurs de toute façon
le vrai problème c'est que tous ces
jeunes restent sur le territoire
national et ce que je demande
aujourd'hui à monsieur me disent c'est
de me donner les chiffres de
l'évaluation de ces jeunes sur le
territoire national je suis certain
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de jeunes qui sont en
situation irrégulière sans que à mon
sens l'état n'ait jamais fait ce qu'il
fallait
soit pour leur donner un statut qui soit
un statut de l'égalité carte de séjour
aux situations de réfugiés soit est pris
à leur encontre une obligation de
quitter le territoire et je considère
que contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre ce
ne sont pas les départements qui sont en
cause les départements font leur
possible pour assurer à ces jeunes avant
la majorité les contrats de jeunes
nageurs l'est ce qu'ils peuvent mais en
fait je ne me sers charrette gens
n'arrêtent là monsieur le président mais
je aimerait raisonner aujourd'hui en
stock et en plus c'est pas un terme ou
des termes qui s'applique à la matière
mais merci faisons le calcul monsieur
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président messieurs le
monsieur le sénateur ravi de vous
retrouver ici après avoir été vous
rendre visite sur un autre sujet
les deux sèvres lorsque vous présidiez
encore récemment le conseil
départemental
monsieur le sénateur jamais mis en cause
les départements j'ai dit que chacun
avait sa part de responsabilité au
contraire et c'est ensemble que nous
pouvions mieux accompagner ses enfants
rappeler quelques chiffres puisque vous
voulez les demandes et ont reflué en
stock dépit du terme malheureux de ces
chiffres sont effectivement les deux
années là où la river deux mineurs
étaient les plus importantes 2016 2017
2018 c'était vingt mille mineurs non
accompagnés qui se présentait pour être
évalués 28000 en 2018 31000 en 2019 qui
venaient se déclarer mineurs pardon qui
était effective du pardon c'est celle
aussi de pardon excusez moi c'est le
nombre de mineurs présents sur le
territoire je vais essayer d'être clair
trente et un mille en 2010 neuf mineurs
non accompagnés sur le territoire
c'était 44000 qui venaient se déclarer
mineurs en 2017 51000 en 2018 36000 en
2019 et n'était reconnu que 14000 17000
et 16000 c'est à dire entre 30 et 40%
qui était effectivement déclarés mineurs
sachez que chaque année ce sont à peu
près c'est une estimation 11500 mineurs
non accompagnés qui accèdent à la
majorité qui ont 18 ans je voulais dit
tout à l'heure une grande partie d'entre
eux arrivent sur notre territoire à 15
16 ans ils sont pris en charge de trois
ans et cessons 11500 qui sont le majeur
chaque année qui donc potentiellement
sortent du système sans un certain
nombre d'entre eux bénéficient de
contrat jeune majeur et donc restent
dans le système d aide sociale à
l'enfance en 2019 ce sont cinq mille six
cent trente titres de séjour qui ont été
délivrés à des mineurs non accompagnés
et 400 titres qui ont été refusées voilà
les chiffres dont je peux dont je
dispose et que je peux partager avec
vous s'agissant des titres délivrés à
ces mineurs lorsqu'ils atteignent leur
majorité ministre la parole est à mme
hussein bourgi pour le groupe socialiste
pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre évoqué un sujet aussi sensible
aussi sérieux et aussi grave comme nous
le faisons aujourd'hui oblige à parler
avec générosité
mais aussi avec lucidité et gravité dans
mon département comme dans beaucoup de
départements et l'intervention de madame
delattre tout à l'heure en attestent
nous avons des mineurs non accompagnés
qui arrivent et des jeunes majeurs qui
arrive qui viennent de pays où il y à la
guerre ces jeunes ces enfants traversent
des pays traverse des continents
traverse des mères parfois au péril de
leur vie avec l'objectif pour la grande
majorité d'entre eux de venir travailler
pour envoyer de l'argent à leurs
familles
mais la vérité m'oblige à dire qu'il ya
aussi des filières mafieuses des
filières mafieuses qui font venir ces
enfants qui les utilisent et qui vont
provoquer un vrai problème d'ordre
public qui va jeter le discrédit sur
l'ensemble des mineurs non accompagnés
dans mon département de l'hérault il y
as très précisément 77ème ena qui ont
été mises en cause l'année dernière en
2020 dans 254 infraction soixante dix
sept mineurs non accompagnés mise en
cause dans deux cent cinquante quatre
infractions et systématiquement
lorsqu'il passe devant la justice on les
remet en liberté à la charge du
département
même lorsqu'ils sont jeunes majeurs
alors monsieur le ministre je vais vous
dire la conviction sur le sujet il ya
90% des mails à dans mon département une
pose aucun problème et j'ai l'honneur et
la fierté dans parrainer un certain
nombre et notamment le dernier que j'ai
pas renier a rejoint les compagnons du
devoir le 17 décembre dernier
c'est un exemple d'intégration c'est un
modèle pour nous tous et nous tout
en revanche je suis obligé de vous dire
qui à 10 % de mineurs non accompagnés au
prétendu mineurs non accompagnés dans le
département qui pose un problème et
semblerait que l'état français et
quelques difficultés à les reconduire à
la frontière parce qu'ils seraient liées
par le pacte de marrakech sur les
migrations qui l'empêchent de reconduire
à la frontière des jeunes ou des enfants
et des jeunes surtout les enfants
peuvent aller reconduire la frontière
colas il faut parce que leurs pays
d'origine ne voudrais pas les recevoir
quelle réponse le gouvernement peut-il
apporter à cette situation
particulièrement crise merci monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le sénateur je l'évoquais non
aux propos introductif
derrière ces trois lettres il ya des
réalités et des parcours et des
motivations très différente des
situations très différentes et vous avez
raison je passais 90% mais une très très
grande majorité de ces enfants je pense
sont là pour s'intégrer comme on dit se
lève le matin apprennent le français en
six mois se mettre dans des parcours
professionnalisant et il ya un certain
nombre de patrons qui sont très contents
de les avoir et qui vont voir le
président du conseil départemental pour
le plat il préfère leur disant mais il
faut qu'il reste bon et puis oui et des
mineurs alors d'une part qui sont
victimes de traite qui sont victimes de
délinquants et puis qui se peuvent être
par ailleurs délinquants eux mêmes et je
vous remercie de dire qu'il faut essayer
d'éviter d'amalgamé tous ces jeunes là
c'est pour ça que me permettait aussi de
dire qu'ils avaient des réalités
différentes
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un certain
nombre de mineurs alors vous évoquiez le
maroc ne peut pas non plus stigmatiser
le maroc
mais effectivement un salon de jeunes
qui sont là qui viennent du maroc qui
viennent à peu près de la même région
d'ailleurs tous parce que les filières
que vous évoquez existe bien qu'ils sont
souvent alors soit majeur soit très
jeunes soient plus jeunes d'ailleurs que
les autres mineurs non accompagnés
ils sont pas du tout là pour s'intégrer
qui refuse d'ailleurs en fait tous les
système d'accompagnement et eux ils vont
pas frapper à la porte du conseil
départemental pour être pris en charge
par la zone ils ont souvent de gros
problèmes de santé il faut il faut le
dire aussi parce que ça nécessite voilà
ils sont aussi victimes qui sont
polytoxicomane souvent un ils sont
notamment et au rivotril
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
le maroc je me dépêche nous avons mis en
place une procédure particulière le
ministre de l'intérieur
le garde des sceaux se sont rendus au
maroc à sa robe de juge je crois se sont
rendus également au maroc un travail
conjoint a été menée avec les autorités
marocaines et un schéma de procédure
relatif à la prise en charge des mineurs
non accompagnés a été élaboré il permet
la prise en charge de mineurs à droit
constant dans le cadre des conventions
de la haye cadre qui reste important
schéma de protection de l'enfance avec
une coopération sur la prise de décision
sur le retour de mineurs au maroc en
fonction de la situation du mineur et
notamment pour les une coopération pour
l'exécution du retour de ces mineurs au
maroc en fonction de sa situation c'est
une circulaire du 8 février 2021
je vous y renvoie je suis déjà le temps
me manque où il ya le schéma de
procédure relatif à la prise en charge
de ces mineurs une questionnaire
régulation sociale et un formulaire si
monsieur me d'antin supervision
bilatérales avec ce pays là
spécifiquement pour traiter ces sujets
la parole est à stéphane saute sautarel
pour le groupe des républicains pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la question des mineurs non
accompagnés ex mineurs isolés étrangers
qu'ils demeurent néanmoins relèvent
d'abord d'un sujet migratoire donc de
l'état le président de la république
l'avait d'ailleurs reconnu avant le
congrès de rennes de l'adf en 2018
et pour ma part à l'issue de ce débat je
veux attirer votre attention sur le
continuum de la protection de l'enfance
qui doit concerner les amène à comme
tous les enfants pris en charge par
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
en effet ces jeunes bénéficient d'un
accompagnement de la zone au titre du
contrat jeune majeur
or nombre d'entre eux doivent mettre un
terme à leur parcours d'insertion en
raison de leur situation administrative
alors qu'ils sont engagés dans un
parcours scolaire et ou d'apprentissage
la majorité faute de titre de séjour les
condamne les mêmes pour lesquels l'état
a demandé aux conseils départementaux
d'assurer la protection et la prise en
charge inconditionnel s'en suit parfois
chassé par ce même état de manière
aveugle alors qu'ils sont bien souvent
en phase d'insertion et de construction
d'un nouveau projet de vision
les services de la zone instruisent
régulièrement une demande d'asile auprès
de l'eau fera ou d'accession à
nationalité française lorsque cela est
possible mais se heurte à des blocages
liés bien évidemment au fait que ces
jeunes amènent à ne disposent souvent
pas de documents d'état civil
authentifié par les services de la paf
bref nous sommes dans un call kafkaïen
qui génère de véritables drames humains
ces parcours interrompu stop
l'engagement de ces jeunes
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre il
met aussi en difficulté des entreprises
qui avaient investi dans leur parcours
d'apprentissage et qui se trouve accusé
d'avoir recours au travail clandestin
ce n'est acceptable ni pour les jeunes
ni pour les entreprises ni pour les
professionnels de la zone qui voient
leur mission n'y ait ni pour nos
finances publiques qui ont investi
investi sur ses jeunes pour les
abandonner ensuite maman département le
cantal par exemple plusieurs jeunes sont
dans cette situation et les réponses
administratives à porter qui confirme à
qui confine pas dans l'impuissance sont
désespérantes pour tous y compris pour
notre reconquête démographique
alors monsieur le ministre quand
mettrez-vous de la cohérence et des
moyens pour une gestion responsable et
solidaire de la situation de ces jeunes
sourds bon merci à monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous risque de me répéter un
peu mais c'est je crois tout le sens de
ce que nous essayons de faire pour les
mineurs non accompagnés également pour
les jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
parce que la question de la majorité de
la fin de la prise en charge d'un
certain nombre de cas par les services
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance ase 18 ans
vous le savez s'agissant de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance sous la main certain
nombre de questions difficulté une
situation dramatique parfois avec ce
qu'on appelle les sorties sèches et un
certain nombre de jeunes qui du jour au
lendemain ne sont plus pris ne sont plus
prises en charge donc dans un cas comme
dans l'autre c'est la raison pour
laquelle là je pense là pour le coup que
la coopération entre l'état et les
départements et ce continuum que vous
évoquiez doit être doit être mobilisée
au maximum donc c'est tout le sens
s'agissant de l'insertion
professionnelle de cette convention que
j'évoquais avec l'union nationale des
missions locales auxquelles nous avons
adjoint une contribution financière de
la part de l'état de 500 euros pour tout
jeune qui ne serait pas dans un parcours
d'études ou d'insertion pour éviter
justement ces fameux sorties sèches et
je précise ici que ça n'a pas vocation à
se substituer à un éventuel contrat
jeune majeur ou en tout cas à
l'accompagnement éducatif qui pourrait
continuer à être nécessaire de la part
du département
et puis par ailleurs dans le cadre de la
régularisation administrative cette
nécessité de mieux anticiper les
situations
effectivement faire sortir tout le monde
de l'incertitude actuelle le à commencer
par le jeune évidemment le département
aussi parce qu'il sait pas ce qu'il va
devoir continuer à s'occuper de ce jeune
là c'est huit ans et puis les patrons
les chefs d'entreprise mais j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure qui effectivement sont face à
des situations
donc essayons d'anticiper de mieux nous
coordonner de mieux coopérer de mieux
accompagner ces jeunes là est
effectivement de faire en sorte que cet
investissement qui a été fait sur ces
jeunes là et je le dis avec emphase et
valeurs très positive ne soit pas perdue
pour l'avenir parce que ça se pourrait
s'apparenter effectivement du gâchis
dans un certain nombre très grand nombre
de cas merci monsieur le ministre pour
conclure les débats la parole est à
monsieur arnaud bazin pour le groupe est
républicain pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues conclure un
tel débat est une gageur c'est évident
en tout cas mon propos qui va relever
certains des points qui ont été traités
n'a pas vocation à mettre ce point final
bien évidemment mais à faire saillir
quelques points le point principal sur
lequel vous recommencez c'est la
nécessité le caractère indispensable du
débat que nous avons eu et les seize
orateurs ont évoqué toutes les
dimensions de ceux de ce débat en effet
une politique publique qui voit son
volume multiplié par 12 par 13 voire
davantage en cinq à sept ans doit nous
interroger en tant que responsable
public
quelles en sont les causes examinons les
conséquences essayons de comprendre ce
qui se passe ensuite ça a été dit aussi
monsieur le ministre il s'agirait d'une
compétence départementale majeur une
compétence particulièrement sensible et
même emblématique de l'action sociale
des départements pour avoir siégé
pendant près de sept ans au bureau de
l'assemblée des départements de france
je puis vous assurer que l'ensemble des
présidentes et présidents de
départements ont à coeur de remplir
cette mission cette noble mission qui
est de donner une deuxième chance à ces
enfants qui ne trouvent pas toutes les
chances dans leur famille je puis un
test et qui dit sont tous très attachés
et c'est justement ça qui les amène à
s'inquiéter de cette situation de
dégradation ensuite troisième point de
nécessité absolue de débats ce parce que
les départements qui sont la cheville
ouvrière de ces politiques sont déjà en
grande difficulté pour d'autres raisons
bien évidemment les dépenses sociales
n'ont cessé de croître
57 à 60 % de leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement maintenant on peut
s'attendre avec on peut s'attendre on
peut déjà constater pardon avec la crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences
économiques que le rsa encore augmenter
et dans beaucoup de départements a plus
de chiffres c'est tout à fait
considérable
et puis d'autre part pèse sur les
départements des risques importants sur
leurs recettes notamment les droits de
mutation à titre onéreux dans ce
contexte de crise l'impact a été déjà
soumis à plusieurs reprises il est très
lourd je n'y reviens pas et quatrième
point depuis dix ans nous sommes content
nous sommes confrontés dans les
départements
à une surdité chronique de l'état qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte déjà ancien
de maltraitance des départements par
l'état je vous renvoie au rapport de la
mission d'information au report de
cécile cukierman dans cette mission j'ai
eu l'honneur de présider sur la place
des départements dans les grandes
régions
vous connaissez tous les droits des
différentes étapes de la disparition
programmée des départements avec les
lois notre madame l'étranglement
financier de ces départements avec
notamment la baisse de la dotation de
fonctionnement pendant le quinquennat
précédent de 40% ce qui est quand même
considérant voilà donc un débat
absolument nécessaire dans une situation
particulièrement compliqué et puis nous
sommes là aussi face à un angle mort des
politiques migratoires s est apparu très
clairement pendant l'ensemble du débat
parce que nous avons à faire maintenant
un phénomène économique
l'eldorado européen on continue à
attirer les jeunes fragilisés ou pas
d'ailleurs dans leur pays et leurs
familles qui souvent les mandatent pour
en effet être source de revenus pour
divers besoins qu'ils estiment avoir par
la suite ce phénomène économique est
adossé ça a été aussi dit à un phénomène
mafieux évident nous connaissons bon
nombre de filières nous pouvons même
vous donner les tarifs par pays et par
région dans ces pays
puisque ces éléments sont apparus dans
les différents départements
enfin et je vous le concède monsieur le
ministre
l'évaluation de la minorité est un sujet
extrêmement délicat pour lequel il n'y a
pas de réponse évidente
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs je pense le
premier ministre de l'époque edouard
philippe
quand il est venu à l'adf à l'assemblée
au congrès de l'adf en octobre 2017 a
pratiquement dit que cette mission
d'accueil d'évaluation devait relever de
l'état
alors ensuite on a considéré que
peut-être les départements pouvait
l'assuré pour le compte de l'état le
problème c'est que les moyens n'ont pas
été au rendez vous
au delà avec on l'a rappelé 120 millions
par exemple de d'euros de crédits pour
2021 sur ce sujet en baisse d'ailleurs
par rapport aux années précédentes c'est
difficile à comprendre mon troisième
point de conclusion c'est que à
l'évidence nous sommes confrontés un
état d'urgence qui est temporairement
masquée par la crise sanitaire qui
comprend bien qu'il est difficile de se
déplacer en ce moment vu la situation
mais qui est appelée à prospérer et nous
en ferions une erreur considérable en
restant sur le même la même appréhension
du problème après cette brève accalmie
je pense qu'il faut nous mobiliser dès
maintenant pour apporter des réponses
qui soit plus solide que celle que nous
avons pu en voir jusque là enfin dans
cet état d'urgence nous mettons en
danger l'aide sociale à l'enfance elle
même dans les départements notre
capacité à assurer de façon
satisfaisante les départements eux mêmes
dans leurs finances mais aussi les
français il a été fait état d'un certain
nombre de délinquants de fait
délinquants qui sont quand même de plus
en plus préoccupant et notamment dans un
territoire d'outre-mer
voilà un droit constant y at il une
réponse possible
c'est à vous de nous le dire monsieur le
ministre et s'ils n'y en a pas un droit
constant il faudra envisager une
réflexion plus large c'est remettre en
cause beaucoup de choses dans ce pays
merci chers collègues merci monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]